so you saw the audience seemed to be
receptive maybe even charmed by some of
what he said but widely here in the
United States he's considered a bully so
what did you think of his remarks you
have to remember most of the people in
the audience were Russians separately
you wouldn't you wouldn't lose points
for laughing happily at Putin's jokes no
the Putin I saw there was the same Putin
you can meet he is very aggressive yeah
he has got charm he's got Flair but he
makes he takes no time at all to make
the points he needs to do and from his
perspective you have to remember inside
Russia what people have been shown
continually is appalling pictures of
atrocities against russian-speaking
Ukrainians and the way in which he's
depicted himself to the Russian people
is as someone who is defending good
standards morality all those things so
being accused of being aggressive is the
last thing he wants even if that is
totally true I noticed in the audience
also was gerhard schröder former
Chancellor of Germany if you're Angola
Merkel and you're listening to this
panel discussion what do you take away I
think will you possibly slightly
embarrassed by gertrude showed her being
there but that's not surprising giving
his business interests I think your main
thing actually is I think Angela Merkel
her patients with Putin began to run out
they had an initial bond because she
could speak Russian they used to talk a
lot and that was in the original start
but sometime around the shooting of the
airliner after that she began to get
more more angry and Merkel's one of
those people you talk to and she's very
very straight and Putin I think does
light to several times too many you know
the we've often cited this John which is
at the opinion polls whether you believe
them or not still show that Putin is
well supported by a majority of the
people in his country right something
like sixty seventy percent of them so
clearly sanctions so far which has
crippled the country have not worked yet
so what is it that is going to make him
pay attention I think they all get the
argument about sanctions you're
absolutely right but it has they do not
work from the point of view of
immediately persuading the Russian
people that Putin is to blame for this
you you're beginning to hear slight
mumblings from the oligarchs although
there was reputedly a meeting early on
where
one of the oligarchs complained to
Boonton about the fact that he was
losing roughly a billion dollars because
of the sanctions imposed and immediately
said well I made you 20 it's not her
it's not something which he thinks the
business community can't take but for
the Russian people as a whole I think
there is a very strong sense that they
think that their way of life is under
threat they also see Putin as a as a
strong man and but that is a very very
fickle thing to change you can be a
strong man who is delivering results who
is seeming to make the economy work
right but it just flicks and it doesn't
work then you become another another
bully he's clearly stoking the
nationalist pride right i mean there's a
patron I understand there's a patriot
park now yes that's open because you
know he'd rather talk ideology they get
to the nuts and bolts of what's going on
in the country because the nuts and
bolts aren't very good no that's that
that's the honest truth is too many
Russians died too young the prosperity
Russia is anchored around very few areas
and it's a very very tough country for
most people to go up in the one thing
that Putin did do when he first came in
is he did he did two things I think he
did write the economy helped by oil
prices and he also had that sense of
self-respect I mean Russia had been
humiliated in some ways he tapped into
those two things but more recently the
oil price has had its difficulties and
when Ukraine there's a sense that he may
have reached too far you you can see
quite some evidence I agree most of the
evidence is that the Russian people as a
whole are still wound up by all this
propaganda and it is propaganda very
clearly propaganda about what the
Ukrainians have done that there is some
evidence on the outskirt you know people
people's sons have died in Ukraine and
that is filtering back you mentioned
energy and I want to get your thoughts
on energy and commodities Russia and
China because sitting to Vladimir
Putin's left was Ronnie Chan who is who
were in the past has least been an
advisor to the Chinese government about
business affairs he was and that was one
of the most interesting bits of it is
Ronny Chang basically said look here you
are here's Russia and China we should be
great allies we should be fantastic
partners in this but actually look at it
there are very few Chinese be
bull in the audience he pointed out that
he was virtually alone and he said
they're very few Russians in China and
that is that is true you go to Beijing
you don't meet a lot of Russians meet
Russians in night clubs in London and
you meet them owning football clubs but
you don't meet them in places like
Beijing and there is also it's a
difficult relationship because the
Russians are terrified by that border
between them and China on one side there
is millions millions of Chinese people
on the other side there's very sparsely
populated Russian territory yeah and the
Russians remain deeply deeply suspicious
about that far eastern border of those
there you know at that conference raised
the prospect of aiding Greece what do
you make of it I think Matt isn't it's
it would be a far-fetched and rather
kind of gambling move so in other words
it's exactly the sort of thing that
person might do it's not the answers he
doesn't have enough money to do it at
any kind of substantial way but in terms
of making an offer that somehow gives
Greece another couple of months and
interposes himself in the West I mean a
lot of what Putin does is about
self-respect it's about putting making
Russia seem as if it's part of it he
left on the instance in Syria when Obama
failed to punish Assad for using
chemical weapons Putin who came in and
tidied that up in the Russian rhetoric
and you could imagine the Greek thing
you could imagine him saying well look
this is what happened Greece has got
into trouble we came to the defense of
our Orthodox cousins which is also an
important part of the booting narrative
and that could be something that
actually also made a difference so the
answer is I think he probably won't but
it's a sort of gamble that somebody in
his position that sounds like him yeah